[Music]
I feel like the reason why um
the issues occurring is because I say
like I'm just I'm General generalizing I
don't want anyone to focus on any
exceptions right at all
yeah
as men from Young
we naturally have to deal with
accountability
we can't talk too spicy because someone
will punch you in your face you know
what I'm saying so
we kind of know our level in life and
what we feel like we deserve
whereas um women tend to get saved from
certain levels of accountability
so in that regards
for example women are more likely if you
ask them what to write themselves out of
10 to say I'm a 10. yeah actually
because there's no real precautions to
acting like you were 10.
because there's going to be a guy that's
going to try and [ __ ] can you I mean
China I'm saying that's true whereas
with a guy we understand I can pretend
I'm a 10 and then no get no girls
so maybe I'm not I have to start
understanding that maybe I'm a six but
if I go gym I'm a seven now if I get
peace on my eight get the call
it's like you are not enough as a man
you know it goes back to you because at
the end of the day guys are just like
what my brother's saying yeah guys are
more forced to be realistic because
let's not even talk about dating just in
general yeah guys are told we're not
good enough in so many different facets
of life just like because me I'm from a
sports background I played rugby I
played American football and I played in
the states yeah and anybody that knows
about sports in the states right it's
brutal bro like if you're not tall
enough if you're if you're too slow but
no one cares bro like you're not good
enough and that's it bro like and from
Young where we're taught this thing of
like you know you know you're just gonna
have to take your lot in life and that's
it and guys are more inclined to be like
okay oh my look in the mirror I'm this I
can afford this do you get what I'm
saying where's just like you said women
really got the license to say well I'm a
bad B even though I look like a duck I
look like a farm animal but calm in it
like boom I still should get a what's it
Prince Charming I'm sorry like and a lot
of these women they're just delusional
because there's thirsty guys online or
in real life that's what I was gonna get
to there you go so if I was to continue
now that's what I'm gonna say so
everybody that has brain cells that's
dating right now should understand that
if a guy is trying to just have fun he's
gonna let the girl have the rhetoric let
her have the narrative in order to get
into her pants so guys are lying to
girls already and then girls are lying
to go just for Comfort just to feel like
teamwork like yes his their lines are
girls wow no no it's true though he's
not even wrong so yeah at this point
Who's telling the girls the truth like
for real like you know like you know
sometimes yeah like I think about when
girls go out and like before they go out
they get like oh drinking and get there
whatever already and they're like oh do
I look good in this yeah
[Music]
yeah I don't believe that because some
in some instances in some instances yeah
there's nothing the girl can do bro
I never said oh again I told you hold on
I told you modern women add in extras I
didn't say all and that's what I'm gonna
say all you have to do is go on
Instagram your girl posts a picture that
picture might not be nice but guess what
this girl's leaving three comments
saying that you're beautiful
what am I gonna say this time I can't
say the same thing I said last time it's
like slay stunning beautiful
the thing is I'll be looking once it's
interesting because amongst all those
comments their man's is not putting down
oh my God that's not like of course not
of course very rarely see that actual
man just just to finish what I'm saying
as well yeah hold on let me just finish
what I'm saying as well yeah so now
let's now let's pay a picture now so
there's guys out trying to [ __ ] line to
this girl a bedroom's aligned to this
girl she's got makeup philhar everything
on because there's certain girls let's
be honest you're going to Instagram not
one picture without filter that's what
they assignment security right there
cool she's convinced herself she's this
ten that she's 10 minutes so now she's
dating and then okay let's even say
she's even [ __ ] some of these guys
sorry she's sleeping with some of these
guys in it yeah
before she realizes I'm not a 10 it's
too late she's already wrapped up her
Madness yeah the mileage is high bro
Honda Civic because anyway like bro yeah
high mileage but anyway I'm like um
Christian Dior let's go here's how I
want to look at it and I want to like
give it some Nuance because it seems
like some people like on the internet
don't understand Nuance so I'm just
gonna like give it like the best I can
as basic as I can yeah so back in the
days when it was traditional men and
traditional women
the men
we would all say went to work
and the woman would stay at home all
right so there was a certain amount of
jobs there was a certain amount of
houses there was a certain amount of
cars there was a certain amount of
Commodities yeah
it's not renewable it's what we what we
make and what we what we use up on this
Earth it goes right so now
womanism comes along
and tells women that
you need to work B you could be as
strong as you as him
you don't need no man
all of this stuff right so now you're in
your own house yeah I'm in that house I
got a car you got a car
we have two fridges we have two washing
machines we have this is how everyone's
living separate yeah I need you to
yeah
what's the point you want to make bro
you don't understand no not like just
like condense what you're because you're
saying every like everything in the
house just like condense it and then
like like make your point my brother go
on okay so I'm just saying in the sense
of
but yeah the expectations are too high
now
you cut him off man he was floating
hey everyone calm down yeah
everyone calm down yeah one voice yeah
because when everyone's talking it's
just noise on the live stream yeah so
please respect the the channel the live
stream what we're doing here yeah all
right so there's the reason why I say
this here big man you got your own
channel bro so when when people get at
you you got all the Time in the World to
sit down on your channel and go at them
yeah what people do on the internet they
take six second clips of what men say
and then they blow it out of proportion
so I gotta Watch How I say my thing you
know what I'm trying to say so when you
when you rush me and make me Rush my
thing and then people from calling from
Trinidad and Tobago saying why are you
saying this
like I'm running a show yeah and I'm I'm
telling you what as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible